Meet Kalpanotavla, the first Indian born woman to go up to outer space.
Kalpano was an engineer,
pilot and astronaut
who immigrated from India to the United States to study aerospace
engineering. After graduating,
Kalpano became a researcher at NASA
and joined the NASA astronaut core
after officially becoming a US citizen in 1995.
Two years later, she was ready to go on her first space mission,
making her the first Indian born woman to go up to space.
Kapana embarked on her second space mission in 2003,
helping to conduct nearly 80 experiments studying earth and space.
Tragically, when her space shuttle re entered Earth's atmosphere,
damage to the shuttle caused the spacecraft to fall apart,
unaliving Kalpena and her fellow astronauts.
Today, Kalpena's legacy lives on
through her contributions to aerospace research.
She posthumously received the Congressional Space Medal of honor
and has had various streets,
buildings, and even asteroids and satellites named after her.
Follow feminist for more history stories like this.